garage Michel David Christian Dufour
bonsoir bonsoir
le gouvernement fédéral va être là avec
9 milliards de dollars en travaillant
avec les provinces en respectant la
juridiction dans s'assurant que partout
pays soit protégé les Canadiens ont
démontré à travers ses pandémie qu'ils
s'attendent à mieux en terme d'appui
pour
envoyer un des forces armées pour aider
de longue durée c'est parce qu'ils
devraient être en train de se passer au
Canada aussi depuis longtemps qu'on a
besoin d'améliorer la qualité de soins à
travers le pays
ça va carrément dans la catégorie je
veux rien savoir
c'est pas ses affaires si Monsieur
Trudeau décide de mettre de l'argent
dans les soins de longue durée il
prendra la part du Québec écrire le
chiffre son chèque il y avait un chèque
à Québec et ce sera ça je suis tout doux
se met dans la position du gars qui vous
montrer comment ça marche il faut que
vous fassiez semblant que je connais ça
je vais vous donner un gros chèque mais
en même temps il révèle au québécois qui
n'ont aucun respect pour les
juridictions du Québec
alors empietement ou non t'inquiète pas
acceptable ou non Michel David on va
mourir va encore parler de ça
et ça
[Musique]
bah c'est vrai depuis un demi-siècle ces
deux grands thèmes du fédéralisme
canadien le déséquilibre fiscal parce
que l'argent est plus alors que sur la
nationale
c'est réglé.
[Musique]
Gouvernement
du Québec
il faut pas
l'annonce que
c'était encore il parlait une autre
équipe du Canada anglophone
alors je pense que c'est certainement la
position de on va voir si ils sont
réunis que ça serait une entente comme
celle et comme comme ça comme ça ce
serait pas il peut pas vraiment dire je
vous donne un chèque au Québec avec pote
conditions
en fait
un bon coup un exemple mais je trouve
que c'est bien ça il pourrait très bien
tous les transferts
plus précis de tous les partis sur le
documentation des transferts en santé
pour les provinces on écoute c'est deux
chefs l'on revient
je vais avoir un approche quand même
partenaire je vais augmenter les
transferts en santé à chaque année sans
condition dans une manière imprévisible
et on va utiliser 6 % comme une minimum
je vais toujours respecté les champs tes
compétences des provinces
les conservateurs et les libéraux au
couper les transferts en santé jusqu'à
tout doux à continuer les mêmes coupeur
de on veut investir dans une assurance
médicament universelle on veut augmenter
les transferts on veut aider pour
défendre notre système de santé publique
donc oui Christian je donne à part la
question plus fondamentale c'est les
transferts en santé
ouais c'est vrai ce que dit monsieur ou
tu le sais de la musique pour les
oreilles de Monsieur logo aucune
condition c'est vrai que
avortement
Droit et liberté de conscience la hier
monsieur a répété deux fois sur le
tarmac Québec je suis pro choix je suis
proche choix je suis arrêté de me poser
la question aujourd'hui
on attend on a entendu plutôt par le
biais de ligne dans son dans sa
plate-forme où il dit que on doit
respecter la liberté de conscience des
médecins pour des certains Jasse
médicaux il s'appelle pas d'avortement
spécifiquement et ça peut comprendre
l'avortement est le droit à mourir
est-ce que monsieur est pris encore avec
un problème ou pas
oui et puis avec un problème est-ce que
les droits de conscience que la personne
qui quand même une potion de longue date
qui est inclus dans le projet de loi la
loi sur les
obliger
un traitement de fin de vie
pour qui
à déterminer si c'est vraiment la cause
non mais
elle est suivie et un autre
blague
parce que c'est
la loi
bah il est
pas en question
va demain riz moi je pense à quoi que je
me suis auto
moi je pars avec si vous voulez je
trouve ça très normal avec les gens qui
ont des problèmes de conscience les
médecins de conscience avec obligé d'en
faire
le vrai problème c'est le coq
avec le chef donc
on
au cours des prochains jours
vous allez recevoir mon contrat par la
poste je vais vite à le lire à même
faire confiance mon message pour vous
éclater tous les nationalistes du Québec
sont les bienvenus au Parti conservateur
conservateur va instaurer une
fédéralisme décentralisé est fondée sur
le respect le fédéralisme du partenariat
le slogan et mignon
je vous offre un contrat
cependant le mignon sur le gars n'est
rien d'autre qu'une promesse électorale
est une promesse électorale
à la différence d'un contrat souvent
c'est pas respecté est-ce que je crains
fondamentalement c'est que avant
l'élection les conservateurs ma dope de
programme du Bloc québécois
au moins en apparence et qu'après
l'élection il retourne au programme de
l'Alberta
des promesses électorales du black parce
que respecter ou pas la mesurer bref
au québécois
mais
c'est beaucoup beaucoup
[Musique]
plus loin
changer et j'ai peur que ça soit un peu
la même chose avec Monsieur autoroute et
il faut se voir un peu par exemple la
déclaration d'impôts une réclamation de
Monsieur Lebeau
est-ce que d'abord les gens écoutent ou
pas dans le reste du Canada que c'est
appelle ou québécois comme ça
oui mais probablement qu'ils vont
rappeler ou canadien qui va à
l'extérieur de Québec ce à quoi Monsieur
auto
centralisateur on vient de voir un
gouvernement fédéral qui semblait très
populaire qui a pris
beaucoup plus
parce que il était tellement
c'est un très très bon parce que nous
disent
depuis plusieurs mois il faut pas que
c'est con ça c'est au Québec parce que
on
sera plus là OK
ou pas
ça c'est tellement grave s'ils reprocher
à Monsieur
qu'elle aurait dû en fait de dire c'est
dommage parce que dommage parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui est très respecté
c'est gros comme je disais merci
beaucoup à bientôt au revoir bonne
soirée